well we're always hopeful and uh as you
know the negotiations are continuing
uh we've got our teams still out there
in brussels
and uh you know if there's if there's uh
a big offer a big change in what they're
saying then i must say
that i've yet to see it unfortunately at
the moment as as you know there are two
key things where we
we just can't seem to uh to make
progress and that's the
it's kind of ratchet clause they've got
in to keep the uk
uh locked in uh to whatever they want to
to do in terms of
legislation which obviously doesn't work
and then there's the the whole issue of
fish
where you know we've got to be able to
take back control of our of our waters
so
there's a way to go uh we're hopeful
that progress
can be made but i've got to tell you
that from where i stand now
uh here in blithe uh it's looking it's
looking you know
very very likely that we'll have to go
for
a solution that i think would be you
know
wonderful for the uk we'd be able to do
exactly what we want from
uh from january the first obviously it
would be uh
different from what we'd set out to
achieve but i've no doubt that this
country
can get ready and as i say come out on
world trade terms
we speak to our political correspondent
tom brainer who's in westminster for us
about this
boris johnson trying to put a gloss on
the no deal
reality that's staring us in the face if
they aren't able to make this deal by
sunday a little bit more optimistic than
what we heard
uh this morning from a government
minister who said we'll be able to
survive not exactly
a ringing endorsement yeah i think there
was sort of three
notable points from that statement from
the prime minister the first the
implication
uh that as far as he is concerned it is
for the eu
to move and to offer uh something rather
than the uk government when he said if
there is a big offer or a big change
in what they are saying then i need i'm
yet to see it i think that is something
where
uh you know may that may raise some
eyebrows in brussels who feel that
it's the uk that needs to uh make some
move if there is to be some form of
agreement i think the other thing that
was interesting
is that he referred to this the aspect
of disagreement on the
level playing field which is the degree
to which uh the uk and the eu would
agree
to maintain uh standards of regulations
he said
describe the ratchet clause as being
something that keeps the uk locked into
whatever they want to do in terms of
legislation
which obviously doesn't work well i
think we'll hear more from michelle in a
moment in brussels about this but
earlier
deny and the eu representative there was
saying that
ultimately the uk would be able to
choose not to follow uh
in the steps that the eu takes it would
simply be the case that that decision
would
incur some consequence in terms of the
market but of course the uk says that
that's a false choice because if
the eu were able to wield the threat of
tariffs
in the event that the uk didn't follow
its regulatory
changes then that is akin uh to being
forced to follow
so i think there what you're seeing is
the contours of where that dispute is
in other words how do people does either
side determine
what is a regulation they have to follow
and should it be
a unilateral decision of the eu to say
that the uk must follow or face
reduced market access or tariffs or
should it be something that goes via
some form of arbitration i think these
are the areas where people
are going to be discussing potential
ways forward over the next few days and
of course sunday has been identified
both by the uk government and indeed the
eu
as a point at which they need to take an
assessment as to whether or not there is
any
reason or point to continuing talks but
uh fundamentally it's worth noting that
ultimately what they're saying is
uh whether the assessment on sunday will
be about whether the conditions
are there to continue talks they're not
saying there has to be a deal itself
agreed uh or by sunday which is uh what
some people have
it seems interpreted from what we've
heard in the last few days one final
point i think just worth pointing out
is at the end there boris johnson said
uh that if a trade deal
isn't agreed then the uk uh will be able
to come out on world
trade terms now of course in the last
few days in fact the last few weeks he's
been referring to it as
australia-style arrangements uh been
accused
uh by his critics of trying to put a
positive gloss on what would be
leaving without a trade deal now
following some comments by malcolm
turnbull the former australian prime
minister last night who said that the
australian terms
of trade with the eu weren't necessarily
all that good
i think it's interesting that boris
johnson appears to have dropped that
reference point
is now explicitly saying world trade
organization terms